bom né é o melhor eu sou muito de cinco
patas quer um biscoito
eu sei que tu que és tu bispo leitor tu
és um pronto agora cê biscoito não é o
adoro é só ruim das minhas coisas as
minhas meias minha manta os meus lençóis
as minhas cadeiras mijavam chão cágado
no chão não sei o que eu pago
mensalmente são pedro biscoito eu sei
que tu queres que eu fiz um biscoito
aqui mas não vais ter por este é o como
editar um cachorro e
a bota
e aí
e eu só uso que tenha sempre um
sorrisinho não deixa seu like sala não
basta não cozinho eu sou uso cachorrinho
muito fofo eu consigo pegar sem sujar o
quê
e vai parar pa ponta tudo aquilo que tu
fazes do que conta pessoas de tudo
aquilo que tu fazes no que estou a
sentir alguém irritado estou a sentir
olha aí também de se inscrever no meu
deus pela ford ka ka ka
e ai não consigo essa aula vem cá vem cá
e eu sei onde tu está soltinha que não
pode esconder de mim o seu tio dono eu
faço tudo por esse cachorro eu tenho
água eu tenho comida e mesmo assim o
trabalho do meu chão olha que interessa
aqui é que tá o teu cocó cocó e
e aí
o youtube não tente escolher e eu sei
onde tu estás vem cá vem cá vem cá o que
se passa seu que não gostas do teu
cheiro é cocó cheiro os meus dedos e não
é um
e o edu edu matador de cobras como aviso
que não é demônio e o que você que tem o
direito não é não é não não é
e o meu deus como é que vocês têm deve
ser tão nervosa meu tu tiveres mesmo
molho escuro
e eu não tenho onde agora eu gostaria
que é água não precisa não é
e ai eu não quero não sabia que não te
respondi seu tempo está eu posso atingir
qualquer distância eu sou o arcanjo da
nerf dos guerreiros do eu sou 3211
e eu só quero comprar cachorro que não
rói os meus cobertores que não é que não
está assistindo perceber isto suzuki aí
que eu não quero que faça não é assim
que esse mês sai não sei que tu estás aí
é o demônio dos cachorros que estou
achando que eu estou assim muito chata
estou a ser muito chato
o que é o ela adormeceu que não está
brincadeiras que eu tenho pena do meu
animalzinho chinelo construída nesse
momento é nesses momentos o que que eu
vou tirar o demônio e
o meu cachorro ainda está possuído assim
ou não ai meu deus ai que eu vou ter uma
resposta ai que deixarem muito like
[Música]
escuta bem eu sou a
e parece ficar excitado assim sem
qualquer pessoa agora a sério mas o que
está um pouquinho assustado porque eu
acabei de fazer porque ele fica
intimidade com a câmera né mas fiquem
descansados que eu vou tratar muito bem
dele pessoal especial uma brincadeira
respeita muito de você animaizinhos de
estimação e é normal que eles façam cocô
e xixi dentro de casa né porque eles
soubessem ainda não sabem mas ele gosta
ele gosta de dormir que tenho também
gosto do cachorrinho que tenho por isso
pessoal deixe muito like aqui neste
vídeo espero que tenham gostado se
quiser que eu faço um como irritar um
cachorro dois comentem também e é isso
pessoal vamos muitos tamo tudo aqui e
tchau